were you ever a romantic guy you know
you know I what's your idea of it that's
that's yeah well you know i-i've my my
idea of romance has always been that's
at the guys first and then you give your
idea of romance
Gilbert what's your idea of romance like
what would you if you're trying to get
response where you met Cindy and you
thought you know I want to do this for
her and make her feel some type of way
what are your moves well I'll tell you
what I did for Valentine's Day because I
think we were also having our 3-year
itch and I had can become businesslike
and busy she left for out-of-town for
about a week and a half to Europe so it
was during Valentine's Day solely
Valentine's Day from Prague yeah so I
wrote her a letter every day leading up
to Valentine's Day which I don't write
because it takes me too long and I have
horrible handwriting so I wrote her a
letter every single day she would I told
her to open one every day and then
leading up to a very long letter oh
you're gonna make me cry I'm actually
tearing up can you not tell that's
that's like kdrama [ __ ] why the [ __ ] did
you say that story you son of a [ __ ]
George you talk about you [ __ ] me man
I'm good for you Bobby I think I like
buy flowers every every other time I go
to the grocery store just you [ __ ]
[ __ ] face no you buy flowers every
other day that's aggressive another time
I go to the grocery store so like if you
go to the grocery store I got to be more
mindful about it no but here's what I'm
going to say let me see where did we
learn these traits is important I don't
think I'm not [ __ ] on you I'm just
saying I I think that maybe your idea of
it might be different from yours might
be different from mine so it's like we
have to manage your expectations
I learned it from movies and the only
movies that I watched that are oh man
take our movies about love loss Avengers
endgame no no about like Paris Texas is
probably the most romantic movie I've
ever seen in my life that's what I've
always as a in high school I saw that
movie and I always thought that that
right there is love what part of it it's
basically a man a man who there's he
can't have this woman right and he's
still in love but it she has to let her
go and she left it's the best that she
left and he is constantly throughout his
life you know struggling with that idea
you know I mean it's it's the idea of
loss wait hang on so you're gonna break
up with me and that's what you find a
romantic no what I'm just saying is that
you're asking me where I learned it you
know I learned it from that I learned it
from dr. Zhivago give me we're at the
end of the movie you know the man that
he loves he I forget I haven't seen the
movie in 20 years but you know she's
with this woman he's in love and then
they get separated because of war right
they can't see each other and as an old
man he sees her on a bus and she walks
off the bus and he he's walking behind
her because he's so old he can't yell
out her name because he's so old and as
he touches her he can't barely touches
her and she goes around a corner and he
dies right so that's my idea of love
that's your idea I love but that's not
that's not necessarily like romance like
I was I was never exposed to 50 first
dates or you know any of the movies you
guys watch I'm trying to think the
notebook I don't and I I will never I've
never fully subscribed and that idea of
like oh you know like long walks on the
beach or like rose flowers whatever but
my idea of romance is a little bit
different to like it comes from tiny
things that are never what you see on
television I think that what we need to
do is maybe
communicate it to me it's it's small
little things that make me feel like
that person was thinking about me and
only me in that moment